Sarah and I actually met in high school.
We've been together for about 12 years.
We sat next to each other in freshman year of high school, math class but...
...this is when Stefaan was, like, probably my height at the time.
We don't have to go into those details.
We just made this decision that we were gonna take a year off and travel...
...and we started saving probably two years before we left.
We have these drawers underneath.
It's even a platform; pop this open, we grill dinner.
We got electricity,...
...we have running water...
...with a 20-gallon tank up in the front.
And then we got all our tools.
We're kind of living like nomads right now.
We didn't wanna plan it too much in a way that was really,...
...we just wanted to keep it open...
...so that we had the freedom to do what we wanted and just explore...
...and be able to get up and leave at a moment's notice,...
...which is really what the adventure was all about.